hey man what's up mr. stork kid where'd
you come from he's from space he came
here to steal a necklace from a wizard
[Music]
kid that's the wizard get on it
hey everybody its Charlie a bunch of you
have been messaging me about this new
spider-man Daily Bugle Easter egg that's
been found that basically references
everything that just happened in that
Black Order battle and there's a really
cool new Miles Morales story from behind
the scenes that I'll talk about at the
end of the video so if you're new to the
channel there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video the
funnier thing about this I think is the
fact that Jay jonah Jameson isn't taking
a shot at spider-man like it's weird if
you don't see spider-man on the front
page and it's not part of some big
takedown campaign that he's trying to
start spider-man hero or menace
exclusive daily bugle photos menace he
was protecting that I'm Atticus if you
take the pictures I'll make up the
headlines okay alright gotta get him
some of those hot spider-man pics if you
guys didn't know Daily Bugle was
confirmed during spider-man homecoming
it was more of a plot point but that
ended up getting cut out of the film the
explanation that the writers gave
actually makes it seem like it was a
good idea that they didn't go in this
direction because the original pitch was
is that Peter instead of doing the thing
like they did in the comics where he
earns money by taking pictures of
himself as spider-man and these really
crazy poses that only he himself could
get as spider-man he would be using
those YouTube videos that he makes of
himself to try and make money so it's
basically the same thing but it's more
of a social media spin on it and he
would be just earning money on the
Adsense
[Music]
so you'd have to imagine that Peter
Parker would be more of a genuine
youtuber but it'd be Peter Parker making
spider-man videos without people knowing
that he himself was spider-man filming
himself with a GoPro camera I wonder
what the name of his YouTube channel
would be and they actually even changed
that during
Civil War so that it didn't look exactly
like a YouTube page maybe they were
gonna use the YouTube logo and Google
asked him for a whole bunch of money
they didn't want to pay up so they just
made it a really generic looking YouTube
page even though that sounds kind of
funny I think we can agree that cheapens
the character a little bit so I'm glad
that they cut that out but there is
Daily Bugle confirmed in New York City
it just hasn't appeared a whole bunch
Jay jonah Jameson hasn't become a really
big character but because Peters gonna
be in Europe for most of spider-man far
from home I don't know if we're actually
gonna see him show up during that movie
and if we do it's probably just gonna be
a minor easter egg and it'll just be
some regular hit piece like you would
expect
spider-man causes more problems again
local man ruins everything the funny
thing about Mysterio who's still
supposed to be the main villain of a
spider-man far from home one of his big
battles with spider-man involved Jay
jonah Jameson it was when he was
dressing up to pretend to be spider-man
to make him seem like a criminal
then his Mysterio he would go to Jay
Jones Jameson and say I'm going to take
down the criminal spider-man so it only
made Jay Jay's relationship with
spider-man even worse even though it was
Mysterio pretending to be spider-man to
set it up eventually Spiderman took him
down and cleared his name but obviously
Jay Jay doesn't care about any of that
he just cares about selling more
newspapers and hating on spider-man the
other Easter eggs on this newspaper are
kind of funny too like the world still
reeling from Black Panthers revelation
in his post credits scene so everybody's
still getting used to the idea of
vibranium but turns out sure he
eventually did make it to Coachella and
they paid off that joke from the end of
the movie you said you would take me to
California for the first time I thought
you meant Coachella or Disneyland not
totally related to the spider-man Easter
Egg but part of this big battle Ironman
also invites Wong to his wedding just
another reason why they're probably
gonna pay that off during Avengers 4 and
actually do the Ironman pepper wedding
I've already done a video about that
they had a deleted scene where they
spend a lot more time talking about the
wedding foreshadowing Avengers for stuff
so I'll link that at the end of this but
when you're rewatching the movie just
pay attention for little things like
that like oh wow they seem to be
mentioning this wedding a bunch of times
they probably intend on actually having
it at some point but I think you know
there's a lot of questions about Tony
and where we pick up in Avengers 4
so not everything is going to be totally
linear like they won't pick up right
here on Titan when we start and Avengers
4 will have a little bit of a time jump
in this newspaper makes it seem like
people will remember what happened in
this big sanctum battle but I think that
Stan Lee cameo scene in infinity war is
a really good reminder that New Yorkers
know all about aliens in its totally
nonchalant at this point like oh yeah
aliens back yeah we haven't seen them in
a couple years okay everybody just stay
inside for a couple hours while the
Avengers deal with this we'll clean the
mess up later that's kind of the weird
thing about J John Jameson's
relationship with spider-man from the
comics is that it usually is just him in
spider-man in the city spider-man trying
to save people something goes a little
bit wrong then JJ blows it up to make it
seem like Spiderman did something really
terrible when he was actually trying to
do something good all right mr. Jameson
stinks Robby there's your page one
masked Menace terrorizes town I told you
he's not you had to imagine he would
have had a field day after that first
Avengers film Avengers destroy city in
battle with aliens making it seem like
it was the Avengers fault that all this
damage happened all these people ended
up dying the reason why you probably
didn't see a whole lot of that is just
because they wanted to save Daily Bugle
for a spider-man movie and because Sony
kind of owns that and at the time they
didn't have that sharing arrangement
with them yet so they couldn't use any
of those spider-man characters but
really interesting fact Marvel did have
the right to make a Miles Morales
spider-man film they used him as a
bargaining chip when they were
negotiating with Amy Pascal for the
rights to use spider-man in all these
big Avengers MCU films I'm paraphrasing
a little bit but it was something like
Amy Pascal trying to say you know we
don't need Marvel we can still do this
spider-man is super popular we'll still
make a lot of money regardless of what
kind of movie we put out and because
Marvel MCU stuff had been so successful
at that point he said we'll make a
spider-man movie and we'll use Miles
Morales so we'll beat you to market with
a new spider-man film it'll be crazy
successful because all of our movies are
successful and it was sort of like them
playing chicken like we don't really
need Peter Parker but secretly they do
kind of need Peter Parker in Sony's
spider-man films had been hurting for a
long time they really did need marvel's
creative in the cloud that came
with being part of the MCU let me know
in the comments though how do you want
the future spider-man films to use Daily
Bugle & Jay jonah Jameson that would
actually be a really easy way to bind
the Netflix shows to the movies because
Karen page works at a newspaper but it's
not the Daily Bugle which kind of pissed
me off when I found out about that but
you could just make her a Daily Bugle
employee she could also be reporting
about a bunch of stuff that's happening
with infinity war and all those things
even though all the Netflix shows the
seasons that are happening this year
take place before the snap there will be
new venom footage coming really soon so
I'll do a video for that when it posts
leave all your requests in the comments
below and I'll name a giveaway winner
when I post a new Marvel click here for
that Iron Man Avengers 4 scene that I
was talking about and click here for
brand new spider-man at bar from home
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]